[Music]
my favorite memory of red velvet is
being called a cupcake every time I
touch the ball in Oklahoma City that was
fun you know that's why so funny to us
after we won the basketball game you
know it was kind of little chat to the
fans in Oklahoma City but it's all in
fun and games but to have that support
from your teammates especially when
you're going through a new experience
like that if it was really refreshing to
see them support and it definitely
showed that big fans getting really
creative and they've really invested in
their team and the sport of basketball
so I looked at it as a positive you know
it was just a lot of speculation on who
I was and why I made a decision to leave
where I was for nine years to go to
another team and you know everything was
in question my character why I decided
to make this decision who made me make
this decision I just wanted to show
everybody that you know it came from me
and I'm still the same person I was
before I made the decision me being with
Nike everything was coming together at
that time and for us to do still Kady
had Katie Tenno and won a championship
I was just it was just perfect
[Music]
you